Give an example okay I genuinely believe  that there is a lot of nuance to your  ideas I generally do not believe you  share all your Nuance online I genuinely  believe you are extremely smart content  creator I genuinely believe you  understand what guest clicks views X Y  and Z I genuinely believe that your  individual who's very calculating what  you say and what you do so therefore I  was coached by you listen  that's why that's why it breaks my heart  it breaks my it breaks your heart it  really does I'm not gonna lie to you why  because first you first we had an a  session you weren't coached by me  I can't put my stamp on that I'm kidding  I can't put my stamp on that yeah we  having fun